an emotional rescue ending in heartbreak
five-year-old rayan had been trapped
inside this well for days
a massive but delicate operation was
launched to free
him can't describe how i feel that my
cousin has gone what can i say
[Music]
my heart is aching too much for him he's
my nephew
my god be with him just like how god
stood with us
[Applause]
crowds had gathered in support but as
news of the young boy's death spread
condolences for his family pouring in
rescue teams have been working around
the clock hoping to answer the
collective prayers of a nation
the hashtag save ryan trending on social
media throughout the arab world
here a camera lowered into the well days
earlier showing five-year-old rayon
alive but unable to move
rescue teams had provided him food and
water through pipes
i managed to communicate with the child
and asked if he could hear me there was
a response i waited for a minute and saw
that he began using the oxygen
rescue teams say they couldn't widen the
well to reach him instead using diggers
to strip away the earth at the side
when he disappeared i prayed to god and
begged him to get him out of that well
alive and safe
an agonizing wait for his family now
tragically over
jillian wolf al jazeera